sico was directed by Alfred Hitchcock
and stars Janet Leigh and Anthony
Perkins and is one of the most
influential horror films ever made when
this film came out it shocked the entire
world but a lot of people didn't have
confidence in it when it was in
production Hitchcock was so enthusiastic
about this film that he didn't take his
normal salary and chose to take some
earnings from the potential box-office
gross
and since paramount didn't have much
confidence in this film they said that'd
be okay and Alfred Hitchcock ended up
making millions on this movie it kind of
reminds me of what went on with George
Lucas in 20th Century Fox was Star Wars
them just giving him the merchandising
rights because hey who cares the
marketing of this film is legendary
there was a six minute trailer with
Alfred Hitchcock himself in it that
didn't show a single shot from the movie
and it just had him touring the
locations they shot building
anticipation for this masterpiece he was
crafting at the time this motel also has
as an adjunct an old house which is if I
may say so a little more sinister
looking he had the theaters follow
strict rules in which no one was allowed
to be admitted into the film if they
were late and he begged audiences to not
share the film's final twist which of
course I'm going to get into spoilers if
you somehow have never seen psycho or at
least don't know of the ending of psycho
we are going to discuss that psycho is
one of my favorite movies it's always
something that I am drawn to remote
locations where something dark is
happening where you don't feel like
there's any protection the police are
far away phone calls are far away help
is far away and this is a perfect
setting for what takes place in this
film which is about a woman named Marion
crane played by Janet Leigh who
embezzles $40,000 from her employer and
goes on the run she checks into the now
famed Bates Motel and meets Norman Bates
the young son who is traumatized by his
mother he seems as if he's almost on a
leash from her despite being an adult
man she has him fully under her control
and this is very telling in a scene in
which he says
a boy's best friend is his mother which
is one of the most famous lines in the
film now what's so unique about Norman
Bates is that he's not like the way
killers are often portrayed in films
unattractive loners who have no idea how
to converse with anyone on the contrary
Anthony Perkins is extremely handsome
and charming in this film and that's
something that Alfred Hitchcock wanted
for this character he wanted the
character to seem like a very likeable
person like the audience could relate to
him or understand him and get behind him
because for a lot of the film if you've
never seen it before you're thinking man
this poor guy he's under the control of
this harsh disciplinarian of a mother
and she's out there killing people
because of course we get the classic
shower scene which you know people have
talked about the death there's an entire
documentary about the shower scene alone
so there's really not much more I can
say beyond the fact that it's still
today it's extremely effective
especially with Bernard Herrmann's
Schilling themes which is still one of
my favorite scores ever and I remember
the first time that I saw psycho I was
concerned about Norman Bates and his
character I felt like men what a
horrible predicament to be in you have
to cover up for your mother and her
insane actions and all these things that
she may do on top of that you're trying
to run a business and she keeps killing
all the fucking clients nice going mom
but speaking of the first time I saw
psycho I was probably way too young but
my mother was very trusting and she sat
me down in front of the TV and it was on
television so it was partially edited
for content I'm assuming and I sat there
with my older sister and my mom I must
have been 6 or 7 years old and I was
entranced I still actually have the
visual of mother and her skeleton
turning around in that seat and the
light shining making the shadow shift
around her skull that was horrifying but
I adored it my older sister however she
left and ran to the kitchen I'll never
forget that i sat there elementary
schooler transfixed by this film and
ever since it's been something that's
always inspired me as I said I'm drawn
to stories like this I'm very enticed by
films and/or stories that have these
remote locales in a rural area in the
middle of nowhere where something
horrible is happening behind the scenes
and the way Hitchcock builds the
suspense in this film and so
our expectations is unparalleled
whenever a film does something and now
no film after it can ever do that exact
thing again without being compared to it
you know you have a classic on your
hands all slasher films after psycho Oh
a debt to that film not just necessarily
because of the story but the fact that
this film happened and allowed it to be
part of public consciousness
this gave filmmakers more rein people
like John Carpenter could make Halloween
without being as concerned about being
so shocking or studio not funding it
because psycho was immensely successful
and because of that success it opened up
the door for other filmmakers to tell
more darkly disturbing and violent tales
and nowadays you go back and you watch
psycho and some of the violence is
almost tame much of it is off screen and
a lot of it is sound effects and this is
why I've said in these videos I've made
for almost 10 years now that violence is
not what scares me gore is and what
scares me it's the suggestion it's how
our brains fill in the gaps of the
things we're not seeing that's scary
because our imaginations are far more
scarier than anything a filmmaker can
show us and that's what Hitchcock
understood in regards to not being able
to do something after a film like psycho
has done it's any film in which our lead
character dies halfway through and we
meet a new lead character they will
always be compared to psycho in fact
I've seen many filmmakers who have tried
to do that and have said I was inspired
by psycho to try this this film didn't
just have a shocking twist ending and
violent murder scenes it told its story
in a very unique way in a way that
audiences hadn't seen at the time in a
way that today in 2018 we still don't
see that often and it did it with so few
things we have a very sparse amount of
characters a small amount of locations
only a few death scenes this film
doesn't have that much violence or
nudity to cut to what we have instead is
the horrifying suggestion of what goes
on behind closed doors the only time I
think this film slips and I'm not going
to downgrade it for it because I
understand that at the time
Hitchcock probably thought it was
necessary is
the doctor comes out at the end and
basically explains the twist ending to
us the audience he's telling the main
characters that Norman Bates has a split
personality and he's been acting like
his mother and we get that incredibly
famous shot towards the end where his
face dissolves into a skull for a split
second there and some people even think
that the chain in the dissolve of the
car being raised out of the swamp is in
some way linking the two personalities
together which you know that could be a
bit of a stretch but I do find it
interesting to think about things like
that that's really the only time the
film steps up for me is it's just a lot
of explaining I understand though for
audiences at the time Hitchcock was
concerned they wouldn't get it but I did
I do wish that he had trusted them a
little more nevertheless psycho remains
incredibly influential and still very
thrilling and very scary today and it's
not for any of the reasons you expect it
to if you've never seen psycho this film
isn't scary to me because there's this
startling shower sequence as I said it's
more frightening because it suggests
things about people that we don't
normally pay attention to the
receptionist at the hotel what's he
doing in his house behind closed doors I
love things like that and psycho
continues to be thrilling to this day
I'm gonna give it an A+ guys thank you
so much for continuing to watch my
series of pre-1970s reviews this has
always been one I've loved and I was
excited to share my thoughts on it with
you thank you once again you're the best
and as always if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]